I'm completely and totally shocked to
tell you I mean I who could have seen
this coming that conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones the host of Infowars
is being accused of both sexual
harassment and blatant anti-semitism by
former employees actually I'm not really
surprised at all two former employees of
Infowars have filed complaints with the
EEO against Alex Jones there's a female
employee Ashley Beckford who says Jones
was regularly sexually harassing her
she says she was also the recipient of
racial slurs she's black
not only by Alex Jones but also by upper
management and colleagues the
allegations include that Alex Jones
groped her but her complaint states that
her complaint states that she was
subjected to different terms and
conditions of employment in comparison
to her non black african-american peers
when it came to her salary wages and
benefits and that in regards to her
dress and her hairstyle she was also
subjected to different standards she
says she was mocked for her skin tone
and called [ __ ] by a senior manager she
says Alex Jones was grooming her for
future sexual exploitation and from her
complaint she also said this is just
weird
that Alex Jones often was shirtless in
the studio and endlessly leering with or
without a shirt at female guests and
employees while creating a disgusting
and hostile environment that's one
allegation another is from a Jewish man
named Rob Jacobsen who says he was
bullied and humiliated by Jones
regularly on the basis of being Jewish
this includes referring to Jacobsen in
the office as the Jewish individual the
resident Jew and Jakob s'en Jones or
rather I'm sorry
the Jacobsen worked for Alex Jones as
fearless or that the video were showing
of Alex Jones it's crazy Jacobsen worked
for Alex Jones for 13 years and was
fired last May what do you think caused
it was fluoride in the water or
something or maybe it's that super male
vitality stuff that Alex Jones sells
that worked a little bit too well
the great thing for Jones and I'm
serious here the great thing for Jones
is that his audience is so filled with
see theorists already that they're gonna
write this entire thing off as a
conspiracy at face value right I mean
everything else is what why not this and
it's sad because Alex Jones seems so
normal otherwise as you could see from
the video we were we were showing our
audience here it nobody could have
predicted that maybe this is what he was
doing behind the scenes well do we have
to take the credibility of the accusers
into account here I know I tend to
believe the women and you tend to
believe the women to you but these are
Infowars employees and they're used to
making things up so right so here what
it there's a case to be made that if you
had the poor sense to work for Infowars
for 13 years that maybe we should take
everything you say with a grain of sand
what will we I mean listen these are
allegations right now from fired
employees you never know whether there's
sort of like a disgruntled former
employee takedown attempt going on we
will see what ultimately surfaces but
there's nothing at all that I hear and I
say wow I just can't imagine that Alex
Jones would do that I'm just not seeing
anything like that here I actually have
something sort of unusual I wanted to
share with you today that's really
fascinating an author and neuroscientist
named Malcolm Collins sent me a copy of
his new book called the pragmatists
guide to life a guide to creating your
own answers to life's biggest questions
I've been reading through it and I can
tell you for sure that it's something
that could really help a lot of people
especially intelligent people people who
think about the world analytically and
the book is perfect for anyone looking
for a purposeful way to apply secular
philosophy to their life and get
organized and really sort of find
meaning in life without the dogma and
the tribalism and there are a lot of
books out there that try to do this kind
of thing by trying to force you to
conform to a certain worldview that's
based on the conclusions and assumptions
of the author whether it's a religion or
some other kind of rigid ideology but
the pragmatist guide to life is
different because the book is not trying
to convince you of anything according to
the author improving your life is not
about being told what to do it's about
sort of finding your own answers and the
book is about understanding the
decisions you make within the framework
of science but it also helps you
understand the usefulness of living
according to your own values and what
you think is important with regard to
your experience in the world around you
and the book is broken down into four
basic questions what's the purpose of my
life how can I best realize the purpose
of my life who do I want to be and how
do I want other people to think of me
the answers to the questions are really
entirely up to you and the author who's
a neuroscientists act sort of as a guide
to help you understand these concepts at
the level of the brain and through a
philosophical tradition called
pragmatism the book deals with some
pretty important and heavy ideas but
it's a very quick and easy read and it
could transform the way you think about
yourself the things you do and sort of
how you relate to your environment the
e-book is only $0.99 there's a link in
the description below this video and all
of the proceeds go to a fantastic
organization called the pragmatist
foundation it's a nonprofit that
promotes science and philosophy please
check out the pragmatists guide to life
a guide to creating your own answers to
life's biggest questions